i said to my colleagues one day in the
editorial room
um why do we seem to have a double
standard
and there was a terrible silence and i
realized at that moment that i'd crossed
a line
i had no idea what the line was or why
i'd crossed it but i realized
i'd stop being one of them and i'd
become
one of you
i'm dave rubin and this is the ruben
report as always guys click
that subscribe button on youtube and
don't forget to tap that notification
bell so you're alerted of our new videos
and joining me today is a journalist
author and columnist for the times of
london
melanie phillips welcome to the reuben
report
thanks dave very good to be with you i'm
glad to have you because i mentioned to
you right before we started here that
for about two years i've been getting
emails and tweets and facebook messages
and all sorts of things people saying
you gotta talk
to this melanie phillips now you're in
jerusalem now but you also split
time in london for for my american
audience that may not know you
can you just do a little melanie
phillips 101 a little a little bio
before we get into the specifics of
of your work your writing your speaking
your books that sort of thing
sure sure well i am a british jew
born and bred in london of parents who
were themselves
uh born and bred in london had a fairly
conventional
upbringing of the type that british jews
in the 1950s had
parents not very religious not very
observant but nevertheless
belonged to an orthodox synagogue
i went to oxford university and read
english literature which fits you for
everything and nothing and
fell into journalism i was
trained though in those days journalists
were actually trained
and we were taught things like
objectivity and
the need to be truthful and the need to
be factual
and the need to separate fact from
opinion would you believe such a thing
and i spent two years learning all these
uh
trade crafts on a local newspaper in
britain we have
national newspapers we don't have
syndicated columns like you do
but i was on a local newspaper in the
suburbs of london
and then went to a magazine and then
went to the guardian
the guardian is a bit like the new york
times but more so
it is the kind of journalistic crucible
of left-wing thinking in britain and
at the time that i went there i didn't
ever really consider myself to be
left-wing
but because i wasn't very ideological i
consider myself to be a liberal now i
know that the word liberal
means something different in america
from britain but what i meant by that
what i mean by that was that i thought
of myself as an
old-fashioned liberal that is to say
somebody who believes
in uh making a better world uh by making
people
uh uh by by prioritizing the good
that people do over the bad standing up
for
the vulnerable against abuses of power
standing up for truth rather than lies
and
at that time i thought that my
colleagues at the guardian
and in the left that we were all on the
same side
and we can talk about this in detail uh
but nevertheless
over the next few years i realized that
uh this was a big mistake
and that while i still believed in all
those things they were on the other side
they were the people who actually were
the oppressors of the poor and
vulnerable they were themselves
racist and anti-semitic and during this
period which took
10 20 years um i changed also
in the sense that i became more aware of
my jewish background my jewish identity
became more important to me
and i became very very aware of the
enormity of the big lies being told
about
israel would you believe i'd never
been to israel and never wanted to go
until about the year 2000
the year 2000 was the first time i went
and i didn't particularly like it
for various reasons and then within two
or three years
i had bought a place in jerusalem
because my life
and my whole view of the world and my
view of myself as a british jew
had completely changed so that's a very
short
thumbnail sketch of my descent from
being the kind of
wise child of the left being the
she-devil of the western hemisphere
yeah well i'm not sure how much you know
about my story but i think a lot of my
audience is going dave
we've kind of heard this before because
that in many ways although
we're not the same age we're not from
the same country uh the story that you
just told of coming from the left
from a largely jewish secular family i
mean it's very much the same story and i
think in many ways
our politics and the way you laid out
what true liberalism is
really really do line up so can you talk
a little bit because i get this question
constantly now can you talk about when
and why you started to see the split
within the left towards socialism
progressivism whatever you want to call
it
versus the liberalism that you just
described
yes well there was one particular
punctuation mark
which really set me on this path and it
was in 1982
and it was when in a conversation with
my colleagues at the guardian i was an
editorial writer and um i thought of
them
as being just like me uh liberal in the
best sense
uh committed to truth and reason
and decent people and
uh we had a conversation in which i was
very troubled
by what at the time seemed to me to be
the disproportionate attention
being paid to what israel was doing in
its war in lebanon
which was a controversial war but it was
being portrayed falsely
as a war of aggression whereas i knew
and don't forget i'd never been to
israel and didn't really want to go and
wasn't really my thing but i
knew that it was trying to root out the
palestinian liberation organization and
stop it from attacking
israelis and the plo at that time was in
southern lebanon but it was being
represented falsely as a war of
aggression and
at the same time out of the woodwork
came unbridled anti-semitism that
we british jews are all considered to be
basically all sticking together in a
clannish kind of way and defending
israel
and i was very troubled by this and i
was very troubled by the fact that
the guardian was spending such a
disproportionate amount of its time
in hurling terrible uh uh
obloquy at israel over all this whereas
at the same time
president assad the father of the
current president assad
had caused a massacre
of his political opponents something in
between 15
and 40 000 of his opponents uh were
killed over the course of a couple of
weeks and that story didn't really have
much traction at the guardian i
i couldn't understand i was different
person then didn't really get
understand what i was dealing with and i
said to my colleagues one day in the
editorial room
um why do we seem to have a double
standard
and there was a terrible silence and i
realized at that moment that i'd crossed
a line i had no idea what the line was
or why i'd crossed it but i realized
i'd stop being one of them and i'd
become
one of you and they said
well of course there's a double standard
after all they said to me
like you and i became you and by you
they meant
israel and i'd never been to israel like
you
we in the west are brought up to believe
in the sanctity of life respect for
human rights human dignity
whereas people in the developing world
are not brought up to believe
any of those things and so if they kill
people we cannot judge them by our
standards
that would be racism and i thought
what and i said to them what are you
saying that if one is unfortunate enough
to be born and
bred into the developing world
then one does not then have the same
rights to life and liberty
that we do to my mind
that's racism and they said why are you
so upset
we do you and i became you again the
great honor
of assuming that you are like us
uh you have the same moral standards as
us and what's more
you tell us that you as the jewish
people
are morally superior to us now that
is a untrue and b
it is sheer anti-semitism and at that
moment i realized that the assumption
i'd made
that we were all marching under the same
banner
of truth and freedom and decency and all
those good
things that was untrue that i was
marching under that banner
but they were on the other side they
the liberals the left the people who
assumed that because they were the
liberals on the left they
embodied virtue and everybody who was
not the liberals in the left
was a bad and evil person they were the
racists
they were the anti-semites and they
believed in lies and they were
irrational
and from that moment i realized that
there was a difference between us i
couldn't anymore trust anything they
said
but because i was very attached to the
left
and because i hadn't quite worked out in
my mind what had happened here
it took me a while to realize that we
were on different sides
completely and how i realized it was
that i was writing as a columnist
in the mid to late 80s onwards about
issues upon which i fill up with a left
on every single one so the first was
education the second was the breakdown
of the family
the first was the breakdown of education
the second was the breakdown of the
family the third was
the development of multiculturalism and
the
erosion of the idea that the western
nation state was something
that you should be proud of and then we
went from there into
islamization and then into all sorts of
other stuff
and issue by issue um
that liberal world just fell in on me
from the moment i started
writing that i became considered
i was told i had overnight gone mad
i.e insane and overnight i had changed
my personality like a kind of chameleon
into being right wing very right wing
ultra right-wing extremely right-wing
fascist
neo-fascist and then as i started
writing about israel
um a zionist a war-mongering zionist and
then a warmongering
zionist insane right-wing jew
and that's where i kind of ended up oh
man there's so much here this is like
it's like hearing my story just uh you
know 20 years in advance or something
like that but so much of what you're
saying i think is what
now in 2020 millions of people worldwide
have woken up to
so i have a couple follow-ups there
first off what do you think
is wrong and i hate to say this as
someone that still considers myself a
liberal
in that true sense do you think there is
an inherent flaw in liberalism
that has allowed leftism and
collectivism
to basically decimate it so that there
are very few people
at this point in the west certainly in
america who describe themselves as
liberals the way we're talking about it
most of these
anyone listening to this right now would
say oh they sound
mostly like conservatives i probably
come up
come off a little more on the
libertarian side of that um
but do you think there is an actual flaw
in in the good sense of liberalism that
allowed
this this monster in
perhaps a protection that that
conservatism has
that liberalism doesn't have well
the fundamental flaw in liberalism
um in the way that it's been
developed is that it i mean let's put it
in this way there's there are different
types of liberalism
there's the liberalism which comes out
of um
i would say conservatism or other
conservatism
is a kind of defense of liberalism if
you look at the one of the greatest
uh philosophers of what's called
conservatism edmund burke um
in the 18th century uh now he's called a
conservative
but what he reacted against was the
french revolutionary terror
he understood that the french revolution
which was supposedly all about
freeing the individual and uh
introducing the rule of reason
divorced from religion a whole lot of
other stuff but that's broadly what it's
about
yeah it led directly to terror so he
reacted against that
and as a result he was called a
conservative and he's still called a
conservative
he's called one of the fathers of
conservatism but from where i'm standing
he was actually defending liberalism he
was different
so what was he defending he was
defending tolerance and freedom
and progress and reason these are all
things which i associate with liberalism
now liberalism has a fundamental flaw
it is that it uh it has two fundamental
flaws
uh one is that uh it um
because it prioritizes the individual um
it has been interpreted over time in our
in our current time to mean that
you can't then uh establish
any kind of hierarchy of values you
can't say that one set of values is
better than anyone else's because that's
kind of being
nasty to somebody else and consequently
the logical flaw in that is that if you
can't say that anyone's
lifestyle or culture is better than
anyone else's
then you can't say that liberalism is
better than anyone else's
and consequently you can't defend the
fundamental liberal values of
freedom of speech and tolerance of other
points of view
and freedom of religion all those all
those things which make a liberal
tolerant society
you can't defend them you can't defend
the equality of women
so when faced with say the islamic world
as a liberal today you cannot say that
the west is
better than the islamic world even
though it is
because surely the enslavement of women
must be worse than freedom for women and
equality for women
so that is one of the essential i think
contradictions in liberalism that means
that it's it's sort of
going down the plug plus the fact that
um
it's an it's an it's become um a
libertarian ideology that is to say
it's taken the the notion of the dignity
of the individual and respect for the
individual which
in my view is at the heart of liberalism
um
but uh in my view that can only be
enshrined
by paradoxically a body of laws and
moral values that are regarded as kind
of binding on you
but if you uh detach the individual from
those laws
then you get a kind of free-for-all and
once you have a free-for-all
then it's everyone out from him or
herself
and then you have the the strong
dominating the weak and then you get to
a situation
very fast which is where we've got to
where you don't have a liberal society
you have a tremendously illiberal
society
and that's made even worse by the fact
that this kind of liberalism or i would
call it
libertarianism is actually an ideology
now what's an ideology an ideology is
where the
power of the idea must trounce
everything else you can't ever say the
idea
is wrong so if you come along with a
load of facts
and you say well this idea is wrong
because
here are the facts here is the evidence
that shows it's wrong
well the ideology says you must be wrong
there can be no challenge to the
ideology
and so you have to be stopped you have
to be suppressed
because the ideology of liberalism is
that it's bound up with the betterment
of humanity the perfection of the world
so anyone who stands against that isn't
just wrong
they're actually evil and if they're
evil
they have to be stopped and so you have
this phenomenon in which we have people
who purport to be liberal
who are stamping out free expression
on our campuses preventing people from
speaking
which is absolutely the absolute
antithesis
of true liberal values and that's the
paradox of liberalism it's become an
illiberal ideology melanie you
would absolutely love my book so i'm
going to get your address
after and send it to you because i'm
making many of the the same arguments
and that
that connection between between truly
being liberal and having something
outside of yourself which i think we're
gonna we're gonna get to
in a little bit but i want to back up
for a second because you said that you
grew up in a secular jewish household
that was similar to
most of the others in the 50s can you
sort of describe
what does that mean and and one of the
questions i get all the time
now is what happened to the jews
how did the jews all become lefties when
the left
has become so rabidly anti-jewish
anti-israel anti-liberal all of those
things i mean i think
you can probably trace a pretty clean
thread on that but can you first
describe what did it mean to grow up in
a secular jewish household because i
think that confuses some people
and then and then sort of the road that
that takes us on yeah
well to make people even more confused
it wasn't what i would call strictly
speaking a secular household i mean
certainly
uh highly orthodox observant people
might well call it that but
i didn't think of it like that my
parents belonged to an orthodox
synagogue
they went to synagogue three times a
year the two days of rosh hashanah
and yom kippur we did not observe the
shabbat
in that my parents worked they were
modest people
and they had to work or they felt they
had to work
but we were kosher really kosher at home
and out and um
we had a friday night meal with candles
and kids
and you know i didn't go out but we had
the television on it was that kind of
upbringing and you know my parents were
they they were modest people they
weren't educated people
but my mother was um she had a kind of
religious instinct
um and she was she had very very strong
moral values which i came to recognize
in later years were actually jewish
values but you know i was when i was a
little girl
i remember every night she said the
shama with me
the fundamental prayer of the jewish
religion
she said it with me every night so i
wouldn't describe it as a
secular jewish household but it
certainly wasn't a very
observant jewish household now what
happened to the jews well you see
there's a difference between
jewish community the jewish community
and britain and the jewish community in
america
jewish divinity in america as i don't
need to tell you
is not only mainly democrat but the same
proportion are
uh non-traditional non-orthodox jews
and in america it seems to me
the the prevailing unwisdom of the
jewish community in america
who are the major the majority of them
are not orthodox
is to assume that the secular ideology
we've been talking about
which actually is anti-jewish it's
fundamentally
anti the hebrew bible it sets out to
undermine
all the basic presets of the hebrew
bible the american jews
the 70 who are progressively minded or
secular
um they've told themselves those are
jewish values
they've kind of squared the circle so
they can be good jews and believe in
stuff which is basically anti-jew
now that's disastrous for american jews
i don't need to tell you but
in amer in britain it's very different
in britain
something like between 60 and 70 percent
of
british jews have for the last several
general elections voted for the
conservative party
they are not the equivalent politically
of your democrats at all
but they voted for their to the
conservative party mainly
through their sort of pocketbook really
um but
they have at the same time like so many
conservatives in britain and so many
republicans in america they've kind of
they kind of absorbed like a kind of
osmosis
the prevailing liberal unwisdom about a
whole range of cultural issues
um but they're not very political
they're not very ideological at all so
they're quite different from american
jews however
um the rates of assimilation in britain
are pretty
awful um you know more and more people
are just dropping
out from judaism altogether or
belonging to progressive denominations
where their children
marry a non-jews and they they
themselves drop out
but it's more a kind of a process
of sort of demographic attrition
rather than the embrace of an ideology
which is actually
inimical to judaism which is i think
what characterizes so many american jews
okay so there's many many directions we
we could go from there
but as if we were to sum up everything
we're talking about
when you see what is happening
across the world right now and how
liberalism has sort of failed and that
what that then probably leads to is sort
of
some version of right-wing
authoritarianism or something like that
if you agree with that
premise um what what can we do if if you
want to save
liberalism right now what what can
people do
well it's this paradox again
that to save liberalism you have to uh
be conservative
um and i do believe that
the problem uh uh that that that the the
sort of death throes of liberalism
have been caused not just by the uh
what's happened to the left or the
progressive circles
in the west but by the fact that the
people who are supposedly
who are supposed to be defending the
west
uh against this onslaught have
thrown in the towel a long time ago
largely through ignorance
there aren't there are not precise
parallels between british conservatives
and
american republicans but nevertheless
there are certain
i think uh uh constant characteristics
that um the conservative wing of
politics if i can put it that way
has forgotten what it is in business to
conserve
um and especially i think since the
uh the fall of the soviet union uh which
i think was taking place before
the berlin wall actually fell you know
the soviet union clearly was you know
uh in its death throes for a long time
before that
and i think that what happened was that
um that conservative
conservatively minded individuals or
con certainly conservative politicians
the conservative political class
uh when the conservative when the soviet
union fell it sort of thought
oh our fox has been shot what do we do
now we've won um here is you know the
soviet union having disintegrated it's
no longer a threat
everyone's bought into the market now
the problem with conservatives
is that they tend to think entirely in
terms of economics
um they don't think in terms of culture
they don't understand what edmund burke
understood during the french revolution
it's all about culture it's all about
values it's all about moral values they
don't think like that
and they haven't thought of that for
years so they thought well what do we do
now
everyone's brought into the market what
um
are we going to hang our hat on now and
they are lighted upon
freedom and i remember this happening at
the time and i thought oh my oh no
they've they've had it this is
ridiculous because
the left hung its hat on freedom so what
happened was that while the left
venerated uh and worshipped the shrine
of
personal individual freedom freedom to
do
exactly what i like behave as i like
had the values that i like and no one
can tell me that i'm wrong
conservatives uh said that everything
that's good in the world is going to be
delivered by the free market
um and consequently the conservatives
did not
realize what was happening on the
cultural front they didn't realize that
education
was being redefined from the
transmission of a culture down through
the generations
to teaching your children that your
culture was fundamentally illegitimate
racist
and should be obliterated they didn't
realize that was going on
they didn't realize that the freedom
to junk your husband the freedom to
have a baby without a father even
without the baby even knowing who his
father was and perhaps you didn't know
who the father was
that that freedom would come with a
terrible cost uh
to the child and to the woman and also
to the man
they didn't figure all that out and all
sorts of other stuff so they just
lost the plot and then having vacated
the cultural battleground they then
observed that society was changing in
that direction and they said
oh we can't do anything to stop this
it's like canute holding back the tide
we must go with the flow of cultural
change
and so they became part of the problem
and
that's why liberalism was allowed to
become the kind of
monster that it has become which is
illiberalism
or as uh somebody who was a very
uh distinguished thinker once coined the
term and it's so true
cultural totalitarianism is what we're
living through
my friend michael malus who's a
brilliant political thinker he's more of
like a
anarchist type but he says that
conservatism is just liberalism
uh at the speed limit which i think is
partly
partly what you're getting to there do
you sense that something has
shifted though because i do sense right
now
that it's partly because of trump maybe
90
because of trump although maybe trump is
just the symptom of it
but that conservatives have started to
understand the cultural part
i i think there is a sense of if you
look online the things that are fun
and funny and the memes and comedy the
left has destroyed all of these things
through its totalitarian view
and the things that are actually
interesting right now
are things that are coming out of more
right leaning circles
do you first cred do you credit trump
for breaking through that thing in a way
that the conservatives would have never
done
otherwise i think the election of donald
trump was the
uh the outcome uh of a change that
uh had already taken place um that is to
say
um there are i think that there were two
shoes that fell
that south right metaphor in 2016.
one was the brexit vote in britain and
the other was the election of donald
trump
and on both occasions i think what
happened obviously they're very
different from
different different phenomena um
different countries but they were fueled
by the same thing which was that the
vast
bulk of ordinary people the millions and
millions and millions of when i say
ordinary people i mean
the kind of people who don't have
typically a higher
university education and
who have who had spent decades
being preached at and being scorned
and being vilified and being produced
by the intelligentsia which dominates
completely the universities and the
media
and the whole cultural apparatus and
more than that
dominated politics because even
so-called conservatives the conservative
party and britain republicans in america
didn't really differ that much in these
cultural uh
uh issues uh from the left and they were
all basically
saying to the people you don't know what
you're talking about you're just
rednecks you're just stupid
you don't even have a university
education you're bigoted you don't
what you you don't like immigrants
you're racist
so the the things that ordinary people
value which is community which is
the attachment to their country
patriotism love of their country
and the kind of instinctive
understanding that a country and a
culture
is made up of people who share your own
values you don't they don't have to
look like you they can be different
color faces from you they can be of
different ethnic backgrounds from you
but
at some important juncture they share
the most important values of that
society and that culture
which means that you're all basically
sharing the same
cultural experience you're all attached
to the nation you all
understand what it means to you now that
understanding that cultural attachment
was vilified
as racist and xenophobic by virtually
the entire
political class and when brexit happened
it was this monumental revolt by all
those millions who said
we've been given a vote now and we can
now
use this vote for this issue we
want our country and our culture back
and they voted
to leave the european union and restore
britain
as an independent democratic
nation governing itself for the first
time for decades
and when that happened on that morning
of that vote
when i woke up and realized that that
vote had
happened i had two thoughts the first
thought was oh my goodness
there is a chance that britain can
survive
after all and my second thought was
the intelligentsia will never allow it
to happen and for the following three
years we have had this
titanic fight in britain to reverse the
brexit vote
and then a few months later the election
donald trump happened and in america it
seemed to me your intelligence or your
political class
had a very similar reaction but rather
more i would say
violently expressed rather more
extremely expressed
but nevertheless the same thing how
could this have happened
this can't be true this can't have
happened the people
are stupid the people got it wrong we
have been robbed
of our natural inheritance which is a
democratic
presidency in eternity and they didn't
understand and would not accept that the
people had got it right
the people wanted their country back
they wanted again the rule of law
they wanted immigration to be enforced
so that
they would again have borders that meant
something without borders
you cannot have a nation they didn't
want their cultural values
trashed the whole time they didn't want
to be told
that america was the rogue state of the
world
they will never wanted to be told that
america was the exceptional nation
again and that america stood for values
of which they could be proud
and which they would want to have other
people emulate
that's what they wanted when they voted
for donald trump now whatever you think
about donald trump
whatever you think about him that is
what people
voted for and you know ever since we've
you've see
you've had this tremendous fight this
tremendous fight to get that man
out of office by hook or by crook and
it's the same thing
it's the class who feel
that not only are they entitled to
rule according to their own lights and
their own values
but that it's a kind of offense against
nature that they shouldn't do so and
they have to
they have a kind of moral duty they feel
they have a moral duty
to reverse brexit to get trump out of
office
and so uh that's where we are the fight
is absolutely still on and who knows how
it's going to end
i do not know how it's going to end
obviously and also
i think that you know even if brexit
happens uh
i say even if because um even though i'm
not sure
um although it looks as if we you know
britain is going to
finally uh slow off the embrace
the deadly embrace of the eu even if
president trump were to get elected for
a second term
i would not be confident that the west
would survive
but at least there would be a chance at
least there will be a chance because
if the left gets power again in america
uh or if britain were not to be able to
become
an independent self-governing nation
again be no chance
no chance whatsoever that it could ever
re-estate that these countries
and the culture they represent could
ever reassert themselves
properly yeah god it's it's a dire
warning
but you know i'm i'm basically with you
this is it
it's it's sort of like the grand fight
all the decades of indoctrinating youth
and destroying institutions and
everything else it has
it has sort of all led us here can you
talk a little bit since you're since
you're in jerusalem
why does uh israel always end up
in in the midst of this conversation
that the left has
you sort of hit on this earlier but the
left has this sort of
obsession with this country that's the
size of new jersey that until the last
couple years had no natural resources
and
fights for all of the liberal values
that uh they purport to be
to believe in uh why is there such an
absolute
obsession with that tiny place
you know yeah i think there's a number
of reasons first of all
um uh in the the last four
five decades um the educational systems
of britain and america and the western
general
um have been pumping out this message
that the west
is bad and the developing world is good
um
the developing world can do no wrong the
way the west can do no right
any bad things the developing world does
must be the fault of
the west allied to that is the fact that
the west is supposedly colonialist
and that i think laid
the groundwork for what must be one of
the most
spectacularly successful propaganda
exercises in the whole of history
which was when uh yasser arafat who was
then the leader of the
palestine liberation organization
travelled to
uh the soviet union
and they're concocted with the soviet
union
uh the uh fiendish uh
propaganda exercise in which what was
the truth
which was the arab world trying to
exterminate
the state of israel because it did not
want a jewish state there at
all transformed that fact
into the lie that the palestinian people
were being oppressed and trying to shake
off their oppression
by uh israeli colonialism and from that
lie
developed the historical lies of
middle east history which effectively
wrote the jews
out of their own history and because of
the
intellectual and moral bankruptcy
of the intelligentsia um which swallowed
all this rubbish because it came from
where it came from
and because it told a certain narrative
story about the evils of the west and
colombianism all the rest of it
um this has become enshrined as
unchallengeable truth
and unchallengeable dogma so that's one
reason
can we just pause there for a sec i hate
to have to ask you to do a little bit of
a
a history professor kind of thing but
you know when people look back and they
see the british mandate of palestine
although they usually drop the british
mandate part
they think oh that means that there was
a state of palestine for a people known
as palestinians
and what they mean generally is arabs
now i know you know that's obviously all
not true but could you try to do like a
two minute recap is that is that
remotely possible
just to unpack some of that stuff
because what people don't realize is
it was the jews that were living in
palestine and the other arab nations
were boycotting palestine and
all of that stuff but can you give some
version of that because i think this is
where people look at a map
and they go 1947 it was called palestine
and now there are people called
palestinians that say it was home where
where the jews come from something like
that yeah okay so
this is probably the most annoying
question i could possibly have yeah okay
so history of the middle east the jewish
people standing on one leg
um or sitting on one leg perhaps um
the fact is that palestine was
the name given to the jewish kingdom of
judea
by the romans when they
overran the jewish
kingdom of judea
and drove the jews out they wanted to
completely exterminate
any memory that this had been a jewish
kingdom
and so they called it by an insulting
name palestine
now it wasn't then called palestine
over history when the british turned up
after the first world war ended and
with the great powers of the time france
particularly
carved up the middle east into new
countries
um it was the ottoman empire they were
carving up
and what we now think of as palestine
was actually part of the ottoman
empire wasn't called palestine in as
such but it was then called palestine
because that was the piece of that was
the area
uh that was in contention and uh in
carving up the middle east
um the great powers decided in uh
well what happened was in 1917 the
british government at the time
which was full of what are called
christian zionists that is to say
christians who very much believed in the
redemption of the jewish people
in the land of israel they understood
that this was their ancient kingdom
and they should come come back to it
and they passed something called the
balfour declaration
which committed britain to work for the
restoration of the jewish homeland
in palestine and uh after the end of the
first world war when the middle east was
being carved out by the great powers
they enshrined this in international law
and gave britain a mandate to
run palestine in order
to facilitate the uh
coming the the in-gathering of the jews
to their ancient homeland and to
establish their the
in in palestine uh a homeland again
for the jews to re-establish it and the
reason they did that
uh was enshrined in various uh um
um statements
and acts at the time that the jews were
entitled to this
land not as a matter of privilege but as
an absolute right
why because it was only the jews for
whom
the ancient land of israel had ever been
their national kingdom and so it was
only the jews who were entitled to
return
and only the jews who would be given
political
rights in that homeland other uh
ethnicities and
and and uh peoples would be given who
were living there
i.e the arabs and any others would be
given
civil and religious rights but the
political right that is to say
it would be a jewish homeland uh would
go
to the jews alone and what happened then
was that britain had this
internationally binding duty to bring
the jews back and to establish the
jewish homeland but
the arabs who were incited by
what we would now call islamist
extremists
um who were kind of invented around that
time
in a politic in the sort of political
way that we understand them today
um basically uh started to attack
and to murder and to commit pogroms
against uh both the jews
and the british um and to cut a very
very long story short um the british
kind of threw in the towel
and decided that the only way they could
um
solve this problem um and stop
their own people being killed and stop
the killing
was to divide the land so having been
given this internationally binding duty
to bring the jews in and establish their
homeland
in what was called palestine which
consisted by the way of what is now
israel
the disputed territories called the west
bank and gaza
the jews under international law were
entitled to settle
all that land so the british basically
ripped that up
and said we'll give part of that land to
the arabs you can have an arab
state alongside the jewish state
and the jews said okay
and the arabs said you must be
joking we want the jews gone
and that has been the story of israel
and the arabs
from that day to this time and again
the arabs being offered a state
alongside israel
called a palestine state
a state of palestine time and again at
every on every of
one of these occasions the israelis the
jews before them before it was israel
have accepted on every one of these
occasions the arabs have not only
rejected it
but have redoubled their attempts
through terrorism through war
to obliterate the jewish state that is a
story
in a nutshell of the region
and it's why when you realize
that story and you know there's a lot
more to that story than i've been able
to give you in this little nutshell
you realize the magnitude of the big lie
about israel and then you realize
something else
that if so many people have accepted
this lie
then it follows that they really cannot
distinguish between truth and falsehood
at all they are really gullible
incredulous
and stupid and irrational and that
explains quite a lot
about why the left is where it is today
as well
yeah i had historian neil ferguson on
who i'm guessing you're probably
familiar with from stanford and he said
something to that effect also that it's
just
it's just the biggest lie that they sort
of use to then promulgate
sort of the rest of their lives so i i
have one more for you with all of this
in mind which is
um are you hopeful you know when you
mentioned
that the morning of of brexit uh that
you had those two thoughts you sort of
lit up for a second because
i think it was the the realization that
you know we the people
actually do have some capacity to
control our lives and maybe the elites
and the intelligentsia and the rest of
it
don't automatically own us and i think a
lot of people right now are just
completely worried
that our countries are slipping away and
uh
and all of this stuff so are are you
hopeful do you consider yourself an
optimist are you a pessimist
are you somewhere in between i have to
tell you in all honesty i'm not normally
considered to be a little ray of
sunshine
um i'm normally considered to be you
know mrs apocalypse now
um i've seen some of the clips
until brexit trump happened in 2016 i
was
totally pessimistic i thought you know
the west had had it
it was you know there was no way that it
could survive given
all the things that like we've been
talking about and then these two things
happened
and then we had this we had this
tremendous fight over brexit over trump
still going on who knows how those
fights really are gonna end
and subsequently we had a whole lot of
other stuff uh
of you know different kinds of uproar
different kinds of unprecedentedly awful
events that
none of us could imagine living through
and so
we're in a state of at the moment where
you know the world is kind of
in uproar and it's up in the air
but in this uproar you know
we we don't know how the pieces are
actually going to fall
but certain things are happening um
i think that as i say whenever you think
about mr trump
and i have reservations i have to say
significant reservations about him
i think that the fact that he has shown
that america
is back in business that it uh
is not going to be a passive bystander
to
evil in the world which can threaten
america
and threaten israel but it's actually
going to take a stand
against bad people it's going to take a
stand so he took a stand against
iran for example he did not you know he
he very much renounced
the whole craven business of appeasing
iran which uh was basically leading the
world to a completely
nightmare scenario and still is iran is
still there it still
poses a terrible threat but the fact
that he showed that he was not prepared
to go along with that anymore and the
fact that he showed that he was not
prepared to stand by
and allow israel to be endlessly
blackmailed in the way that has been
blackmailed
and that america and the west have stood
by while it's blackmailed
all those decades and that has changed
uh the dynamic in the arab world in a
way in which we
we would never even a few years ago we
would never have thought possible
the arab world now needs israel and
america
to help it defeat iran it believes that
it can't do it without them
it believes that with president trump in
the oval office
um america will remain true to that
intention and so that immediately
changes the whole dynamic vis-a-vis
israel so from that point of view
alone that is a source of considerable
optimism that's not to say
it's going to be plain sailing at all or
that there won't be terrible bumps along
the way or that iran
won't suddenly go completely berserk and
do terrible things but it does mean that
there's more optimism than there was and
on the cultural front similarly
um you know the the
the onslaught by the left the onslaught
on freedom and on decency and on
morality and on truth
is accelerating no question about that
the madness
of identity politics veers from one
lunacy to another but they're losing
and you know the more desperate they get
the more extreme they get and the more
extreme they get the more you know that
they are
getting more and more desperate and why
are they desperate because they
have suddenly not suddenly but they have
been forced to
acknowledge at some part of themselves
that the lie they've told themselves
that
you know everybody is with us and only a
few
fringe fanatics neo-nazis white
supremacists
racist xenophobes and so on only those
people are against us
it's it can't hold anymore because
millions
millions have voted for trump and
millions voted for brexit
and millions in europe are saying we
want our nations back now
some of that is not going to result in
stuff that i would approve of
i think you alluded yourself to the fact
that some of this is producing
leaders who are who come from noxious
backgrounds
whose views may well still be obnoxious
you know and some of it may turn out to
be not very good at all
but um there is a prospect that
you know decent people standing together
can now win
through um in a way that was
inconceivable just a few years ago
so whether that makes me an optimist
or a pessimist i'm i'm not quite sure
i always say i'm a world weary optimist
i think that we got a little bit of that
right there from you
uh well listen from one far from one far
right extremist
whatever you want to call me to another
i've thoroughly enjoyed this i'm glad we
did it and i hope we can do it in person
sometime
i hope so too i've enjoyed it enormously
thank you very much for having me on
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell